If you’ve been a close follower of this channel
for a while now, or even of the SCP Foundation
Archive as a whole, then there’s a pretty high
chance that you might have heard of SCP-096.
Even if this just so happens to be the first
of our SCP videos that you’ve ever clicked on,
you still might have seen the Shy Guy itself
in various other corners of the internet.
Since the earliest days of the SCP Foundation,
SCP-096 has gradually become one of the most
iconic and recognizable creatures in the
Foundation’s entire menagerie of anomalous beings.
Despite standing taller than any ordinary person,
you might be forgiven for mistaking SCP-096 for a
human being if you were to see it at a distance.
But the creature is unusually proportioned,
to say the least, still appearing almost human
in its shape, but possessing long, dangling arms
that almost reach the ground. SCP-096’s body
is thin and hairless, with opaque, clear white
pupil-less eyes and a wide, gaping mouth - or
so we’ve heard, thanks to drawings provided
by someone who sadly isn’t with us anymore...
But you might be surprised to learn that SCP-096
doesn’t really do all that much. Mostly, the tall,
spindly humanoid spends its waking days mindlessly
pacing around in its containment cell. Sounds
like most days in a college dorm during lockdown,
right? That is, of course, until someone dares
to look at SCP-096’s face. It doesn’t have to be
directly either, it can be something as simple
as glancing at a photo, or watching a video of
the creature. But the moment it is seen, the exact
second it’s perceived, the wiry monster will know.
Having its face viewed in any way will cause
the Shy Guy to really live up to its nickname;
the creature suffers some sort of psychological
meltdown, covering its face with its huge,
claw-like hands and weeping. SCP-096
quickly becomes utterly inconsolable,
suffering from extreme emotional distress
until it simply can’t take it anymore.
Pulling itself up to its full, looming
height, SCP-096 will stand and travel
at impossible speeds towards the
person that dared look at its face.
There’s no way to hide from the Shy Guy,
nothing can stand in its path as it tracks
down this unlucky person. And when it finds
them? Well, it’s certainly not pleasant.
Somehow, without leaving any trace on their body,
SCP-096 will kill the person that looked at it,
possibly even eating them afterwards. Then, it
calms itself down, returns to its more docile
state, and is typically bagged and brought back
home by whatever Mobile Task Force is closest.
SCP-096 has killed many of the teams sent to
contain it, proving itself to be resistant to
gunfire and other forms of conventional weaponry.
As much as being only a little as a tiny speck
in a photograph is enough to trigger the
creature’s relentless defense mechanism.
Nobody can get away from it either, there is
literally nowhere in the entire world that someone
can run to escape SCP-096. Not even crossing
the oceans or jumping aboard a plane is enough
to stop it. And if our community questions
video on the matter is anything to go by,
you may not even be safe in outer space.
The SCP Foundation’s only real way to keep
the creature safely under wraps and contained is
to lock it up and force all members of personnel
to never, ever look at it, while they hunt down
any pieces of recorded media still out there,
waiting like a ticking time bomb.
So, if no member of the Foundation
can look at SCP-096, how do they interact with
it? Well, luckily, there’s a tale that answers
exactly that, known as “A Lesson in Power.”
Doctor Danielle Kowalski, a member of the
Foundation’s research team assigned to SCP-096,
was sent into the creature’s cell wearing a sleep
mask. You know, the kind you get on expensive
flights? What she was really wishing for though,
was a gas mask to go with it; Nobody
had warned her how bad SCP-096 smelled.
Then again though, few had been as close to the
creature as she had and lived to tell the tale.
As a child, Danielle Kowalski had a fear of
stepping into the ocean. Her mother used to
warn her about treading on a stingray and
dying as a result, giving her a phobia that
stayed with her for many years. But Danielle’s
father had encouraged her to face her fear,
to shuffle her feet on the ocean floor, kicking
up the sand so that the stingrays would know
she was coming, and would simply just swim away.
Perhaps if he could have seen what kind of
horrors Danielle would be working with at the
Foundation, her father wouldn’t have tried to
make her so fearless. Maybe there are some
things that it’s logical to be afraid of.
Entering SCP-096’s cell, Doctor Kowalski
could hear the monster’s heaving breaths,
the perfect mix between a frightened whimper and
a death rattle, the haunting sound of a person’s
final gasp of air. In the back of her mind,
Danielle hoped she didn’t touch the creature
by accident. The closer she got, the tension and
the heat of its warm breath against her skin was
making the approach all the more terrifying. She
had been issued with an instant camera, and took
a photo in the dark. Click. The flash fired,
but with her eyes covered she couldn’t tell.
That was good though, that was the point.
If Danielle could see the flash going off,
she could see what else was in the room,
and that would put her in even more danger.
She was locked in with a kind of stingray that
wouldn’t swim away, even if it knew she was there.
Slowly, Doctor Kowalski began blindly
photographing the cell around her,
stuffing each freshly printed photo into her
pocket as the camera spat them out. Over the
span of forty-five minutes, she took a series
of pictures of the entire cell, until the film
in the instant camera had run out. Danielle knew
that she would probably only need one picture,
but better to have more, just in case. Luckily,
none of her Foundation colleagues were around
to tell her how insane what she was doing
was. They were all preoccupied, preparing the
site for its first official visit from the FBI.
This all took place after what was known as the
Broken Masquerade had taken place. Essentially,
knowledge of the SCP Foundation and its research
into the endless stream of anomalies it had
contained was all made public. People knew the
truth now, and the Foundation found itself in the
one place it never wanted to be: the public eye.
The organization and its activities were under
the scrutiny of every journalist on the planet,
and once more information about the SCPs and the
anomalous world of the Foundation became known,
the world would surely change forever. Danielle
Kowalski knew all of this and told herself that
everyone would need something for protection now.
She only hoped her photographs would be enough.
Fifteen months later, Doctor Kowalski
was interrogated in her apartment,
by one Agent O’Brien. He and a group of
fellow agents had barged into Danielle’s home,
demanding to know the location where a number of
SCP-610 specimens were being held. SCP-610 being,
of course, the infamous infection known as the
Flesh that Hates, a disease capable of turning
human beings into horrible, deformed monstrosities
of flesh. Agent O’Brien, and presumably whoever
he was working for, was intent on turning these
creatures into weapons, and the man had little
patience for a former Foundation researcher who
wasn’t giving up the answers that he wanted.
Danielle tried to argue with the Agent, citing
the Berlin Accords Against Weaponized Anomalies,
a motion proposed to the United States Senate
that would forbid the use of anomalous objects,
entities, and creatures as weapons for any
country. O’Brien wasn’t interested, he claimed
that if the Kremlin in Russia had no intention
of ratifying such a law, then America wouldn’t
either. The Agent had his men grab Danielle by her
arm, while he grabbed her right middle finger and
began to push a thin knife under her fingernail.
The former member of the Foundation tried to
stifle her scream, but couldn’t
stop herself as the pain struck.
As Agent O’Brien tortured Danielle, he told
her that the Russians had all the information
they would need about SCP-610 in order to
turn the Flesh into some kind of weapon.
As far as he was concerned, the United
States government needed access to those
SCP-610 specimens to know exactly what they
would be up against in the likely event that
Russia used the Flesh that Hates against them.
And only a researcher for the SCP Foundation,
the former senior researcher of the SCP-610
project, would know where to find those specimens.
“You don't think it's reasonable for the United
States government to want to understand what could
be used against us?” O’Brien asked as Danielle’s
blood trickled out of her finger into his leather
gloves. “Hell, I don't care what you think we're
going to do with it. I want those specimens.”
When the Agent finally let her go, Doctor
Kowalski tried to catch her breath, forcing
herself not to scream in pain again. She pointed
with her other, unharmed hand, to her bedroom,
telling O’Brien to check the bottom left drawer.
She had placed a manilla envelope in there,
containing the only thing Danielle had kept since
departing the SCP Foundation. Under O’Brien’s
order, his men ransacked the nearby room and were
quickly able to find what they were looking for.
The envelope was presented to Agent O’Brien, who
was no doubt expecting to find a file inside,
something that detailed the exact location of
those specimens he was looking for. So, you can
probably imagine the dissatisfied look on his face
when he opened the envelope to find… photographs.
A collection of instant photos, all taken in a
dark cell, with all of them depicting a tall,
thin humanoid creature. A being with long,
dangling arms that almost reached the ground,
a thin, hairless body, opaque, pupil-less
eyes, and a wide, gaping mouth.
Furious to once again be denied
the information he was looking for,
O’Brien disregarded the pictures and burned
Doctor Kowalski’s neck with his cigarette.
In his anger, he said “I think your Foundation
sure thought they were powerful hiding in the
shadows. But I'd like to explain to you why you're
wrong.” The Agent then went on to describe his
time as a member of the DEA in the late 1980’s,
and how he’d been involved in the hunting of
notorious cartel boss Pablo Escobar.
“I had a narco in custody… every bit
as uncooperative as you are now.” The man had
insisted that Escobar owned all of the Colombian
law enforcement, but a younger O’Brien had argued
that, if that was the case and they possessed all
this power, then why did Pablo Escobar’s men
hide their guns? Why smuggle drugs in secret,
and bury their money where no one would find
it if they really had the control they claimed?
Much like Escobar’s cartel, the SCP
Foundation had always moved in the shadows,
a power that O’Brien believed to have really
belonged to the government. “Your anomalies
belong to us. Your research belongs to us. Your
life belongs to us,” he told Doctor Kowalski.
Suddenly, one of the other agents noticed movement
outside the apartment. The second that Danielle
saw a long arm phase through her wall, with grey
skin like that of a corpse, she snapped her eyes
shut. O’Brien and his men all drew their guns
and opened fire on the monster that had walked
through the wall as if it wasn’t even there.
All the while, Danielle Kowalski kept her eyes
shut. The sounds of screaming and snapping bones
and a sickening slurping noise filled the air,
but she made sure not to look. Within a few
quick moments of panic and agonizing pain,
it was over. The apartment was
quiet, apart from strange breathing;
like a mix of a frightened
whimper and a death rattle.
“Run along now, 096,” Doctor Kowalski
told the Shy Guy. “There are worse
monsters in this world than you.”
Now go check out “SCP-096 Shy Guy
ESCAPE - Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach”
and “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy Guy in
Space? The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” for
more on everyone’s favorite homicidal introvert!